er ist der grausame pfeil und bogen
killer von norwegen 34 minuten lang hat
er mit teile auf menschen abgefeuert und
damit getötet im norwegischen kongsberg
vier frauen und ein mann hat er getötet
zwei weitere personen schwer verletzt
ein 37 jahre alter denen der seit zwei
jahren in norwegen lebt ein konvertit
wie wir mittlerweile wissen ein islamist
ein terrorist wie die polizei
mittlerweile sagt wie dieser mann tickt
das hat er schon vor vier jahren gezeigt
in einem wirren youtube video
hallo hallo
ich bin ein bote
corning ich komme mit einer warnung ist
es
ist es das wirklich was ihr wollt und
dann alle die sich gut machen wollen
es ist zeit
bis er muslim zeitzeugen dass ich ein
moslem bin
also dass das ihre youtube video das der
täter veröffentlicht hatten wir schauen
uns noch einmal ganz genau seinen weg an
fünf menschen starben gestern in
norwegen in kongsberg rund eine
autostunde südwestlich von oslo
28.000 einwohner ein ganz kleines
idyllisches städtchen der täter ein 37
jahre alter däne der in kongsberg lebte
und hier überall auf seiner brutalen
tour station machte bei einer apotheke
bei einem supermarkt wie wir sehen hatte
auch ein messer dabei war dann auch
bewaffnet mit pfeil und bogen seine
opfer vier menschen fünf menschen vier
frauen ein mann alle im alter zwischen
50 und 70 jahren
wir haben genau dort in kongsberg ist
jetzt unser kollege bild reporter jörg
völkerling
grüße dich jörg du wirst für uns einmal
diese ja den weg dieser bluttat einmal
ablaufen
ja ja das ist tatsächlich ein
idyllisches örtchen nicht hier in
norwegen das ist von norwegen at its
best das ist wirklich krank war sie fast
dörflich und heute morgen also war die
anderthalb tage nach der tat ist die
stadt wie ausgestorben
die schockstarre hat sich über diesen
ort gelegt nur im hintergrund arbeitet
die polizei weiter effektiv an der
spurensicherung jetzt gerade sind männer
von der norwegischen polizei mit einer
3d mit einer kamera gekommen die hier in
diesem extra supermarkt wo dieses wiese
schreckenstat begonnen hat am
mittwochabend einfach jedes detail noch
mal aufnehmen und fotografieren wir
haben diese spuren dieser dieses abends
haben wir auch noch wirklich gesehen in
der tür finden sich noch einschusslöcher
direkt dort wo jetzt quasi auch der
polizist hinter der scheibe läuft kann
man auch ein loch ein einschussloch von
offenbar einem polizei projektil sehen
dort hat die polizei am mittwochabend
versucht den amokläufer zu stoppen es
war ja um 18.12 als die erste der erste
notruf kam und man hat dann versucht ihn
zu stoppen aber die erste streife war
offenbar auch nicht ausreichend
ausgestattet und man hat dann essen
anderen braten den amokläufer nicht
aufhalten können er ist auch aus dem
blickfeld der polizei verschwunden jetzt
heute 36 stunden danach sehen wir hier
einfach die
beileidsbekundungen gesehen die kerzen
rosen wir sehen eine einige schreiben
von
bürgern die ihr beileid ausdrücken es
ist wirklich alles sehr nah beieinander
der täter es magischen braten wohnte
wirklich nur 200 meter in diese richtung
wir können einfach mal in diese richtung
schwenken wir sehen auch wie idyllisch
gelegen dieser ort ist es ist ja
wirklich das älteste bergbau städtchen
von von norwegen ist auch bekannteste
und größte
wir sehen den kirchturm die sonne geht
auf wir haben ungefähr fünf grad ist es
frisch aber es ist wirklich ja fast
idyllisch könnte man das nennen wenn man
nicht wüsste was hier passiert ist und
wenn man das mal einordnen diesen tatort
wir haben hier diesen extra supermarkt
wo der täter an dem abend auch aus dem
blickfeld der polizei geraten ist er ist
dann einfach in diese richtung weiter
gelaufen
nach da vorne in die apotheker straße
und das sind dann gerade mal 200 meter
wo er dann auf die hütte gatan trifft
und in dieser straße die bin ich heute
morgen gelaufen man kann da in die
wohnzimmer der leute rein schauen
manchmal sind wahrscheinlich die
haustüren sogar offen weil die leute
hier norwegen einfach nicht an das böse
glauben sie glauben an das gute im
menschen und dort sieht man heute wie
vor zwei hauseingängen auch kerzen sind
polizei war heute da haben absperrbänder
gezogen dort sind zwei opfer zu beklagen
zum beispiel eine künstlerin hannah in
der keramik studio hatte und nur 50
meter weiter das nächste opfer bevor
dann der täter um 18 47 an einer brücke
festgenommen werden konnte
jetzt ist ja auch bekannt gewordene
täter ist zum islam konvertiert die
polizei hat sich mehrfach wegen einer
radikalisierung auch sorgen gemacht
selbst ein freund hat der polizei eine e
mail geschrieben gesagt der mann ist
eine tickende zeitbombe hat man diesen
mann einfach falsch eingeschätzt hätte
da die polizei nicht früher etwas tun
das ist ganz offensichtlich und das hat
der polizeichef auch schon so gesagt
dass man letztlich nicht genau
unterscheiden kann wie er prahlt nur wer
macht nur sprüche und wer ist wirklich
gefährlich und da ist noch viel
aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten der
verteidiger sagt es ist weniger ein
islamistisches eine islamistische frage
hat seine psychiatrische frage das heißt
der täter müsse auf jeden fall auch auf
seine gesundheit seinen geisteszustand
untersucht werden
dank als bild reporter jörg volker legen
dort im südnorwegischen kongsberg zu dem
aktuellen ermittlungsstand rund um diese
schreckliche bluttat und zu allen
erkenntnissen über den täter den sie
gerade noch mal im bild gesehen haben
danke nach norwegen dank
[Musik]